so here's some food for thought let's
talk about layers of truth let's talk
about shades of perspective because a
different perspective is literally a
different reality so here's a quote by
Christopher all he reminds us that while
gazing up at the night sky one in fact
hangs off a planet and near the edge of
a galaxy vertiginous suspended over the
infinity of space at any given moment of
our lives as we muck about a flutter
concerned with the trivialities of
everydayness as we tranquilize ourselves
with trivialities we in fact are living
in a different truth than when we step
back zoom out take the long view expand
our minds and consciousnesses and
perception and realize that we in fact
hang over a planet suspended in space
spinning around at a very fast speed at
any given moment 10 trillion atoms
self-organized into a sentient mind that
perceives itself as living off a planet
that is hanging off of space I mean
there is truth to every single thing
I've said every single perspective
offers another angle another reflection
of the present situation there are many
truths there are
they coexist side-by-side and I think
the role of the artist is to to visit
those realities to transcend baseline
ordinary consciousness to change our
perspectives to bring back souvenirs for
the rest of us to consumes art gives us
a glimpse of the other
you